some are saying SMP is going to go from
you know 4 000 it's around 39.50 39.80
to 35. there's a small community that
says it could go as little as as low as
32 which would be a 20 drop off but for
the most part A lot of people are saying
there's going to be a 10 decline over
the next three to nine months and it's
important to know what to do in a
situation like this and how it affects
you so in this webinar I'll be sharing
with you the mindset and the attitude
needed in order to capitalize on the
wealth transfer that will be taking
place it's not the kind of well transfer
that you and I think about that boomers
are getting rich they're transferring
their money over to the next generation
and that's a wall transfer this is going
to be a different kind of a transfer
okay so I want to give a quick shout out
to our sponsor Masterworks let me tell
you what I need to know about this
company why they now have 660 000
members and why a lot of people in Miami
At Art basil these big companies like
Morgan Stanley and Goldman Sachs are
going and talking to clients about
investing in art what do you mean art
well because last year the top auction
houses in America did 18 billion dollars
record-breaking last year art rate of
return was 26 to billionaires and
millionaires are saying maybe I need to
think about art as an alternative asset
the challenges for many years low you
know you guys that are making 100 Grand
year 200 Grand year 300 Grand I can't
buy a million dollar painting I can't
buy 10 million dollar painting but you
can buy shares of it now in a Picasso in
a bank C through Masterworks and they do
all the research they vet out to see if
the painting is this if all the
liabilities on them they go through SEC
everything they need to do to be
structured through the SEC they do it
you simply are able to go and buy share
with these guys so there's a waiting
list to be a member at Masterworks but
you can skip that by going to
masterworks.art forward slash
valuetainment once again Masterworks dot
art forward slash valuetainment or click
on the link below in the description
let's get right into it couple things
here Silicone Valley Bank what really
happened there if you look at this chart
if you look at this chart you'll see the
blue the light blue not the dark blue on
the bottom the the blue light blue is
showing assets
and just five years ago Silicon Valley
Bank was a 50 billion dollar company in
assets and it was 50 billion and 17 and
18 in 19 and 20 went up and then all of
a sudden it went from being a 50 billion
dollar Bank to 2022 being a 200 billion
dollar Bank in a deposits followed as
well but the number you want to look at
there
is that orange color that all of a
sudden goes up what is the orange you
know graph that we're looking at what is
the orange color that we're looking at
so a few things happen here covet
stimulus influx of tech startups okay
Silicon Valley Bank buys a hundred
billion dollar three-year Bond at an
average of 1.7 percent interest rate so
here's how this works
they buy a 100 billion dollar bond from
the government it's safe it's going to
give them 1.7 they're thinking they're
doing great because everything is a lot
lower than that remember interest rates
were super low so like oh this is great
we'll be selling you back to customers
that are coming to us it's going to be
fine all of a sudden it goes to
2.7 two and a half you know three
percent four percent five percent
because we can't do this we can't
sustain this year what do we do here so
next thing you know the chart right here
is loan assets and deposits in 2022 but
look what happens here with their
interest rates of the bonds that they
bought you see the orange that's the
bonds that they bought at 100 billion
dollars in 2022 March 2022 a little bit
before March 2022. that's three years
next thing you know fed rapidly and
unexpectedly raises rates to five
percent in one year we're going to look
at history on how many times this has
ever happened in our economy I'll show
you the history of it two cash and flow
slow down and withdrawals increase as
Tech startups are crushed by higher
rates
suddenly people are running to Silicon
Valley Bank word spreads about Silicon
Valley Bank vulnerable position deposits
withdrawals escalate they're forced to
sell
21 billion dollars of bonds at a 1.8
billion dollar loss to meet withdrawals
once they sell the laws this becomes
realized it's official and then the FDIC
is forced to intervene the next thing
you know is when we hear about Silicon
Valley Banks about to go out of business
one of the 27 Regional banks that we
have in America and then that fear
starts going into people saying could it
happen to me could it happen to my bank
could it happen to a community bank and
next thing you know people lose their
minds on Twitter the government used to
come and bail them out this is not good
if you keep listening to the water for
the next Bank what if this what if that
and everybody's now calling each other
next thing you know you know Chase uh
JPMorgan Chase is coming and those
clients from Silicon Valley banks are
moving their billions of dollars of
money
to chase Bia Vega 20 billion dollars
everybody's trying to get these clients
at the same time but what people are
thinking about is these these families
are sitting their sin if they only save
you know protect up to a quarter million
dollars babe maybe we need to say move
some of our money so Watch What Happens
42 billion dollars in one deal one day
Silicon Valley Bank runs the bit run
biggest in more than a decade when this
happened 42 billion dollars went out in
one day most in a decade so how did this
happen covet pandemic put people out of
work at first we're like this is not a
big deal the government's sending us
money we're going to be fine this whole
you know thousand dollar a month
fourteen hundred dollars a month this is
great Andrew Yang was right we should
send money to people we can't afford to
do it well guess what we printed around
six trillion dollars in the last three
years the Federal Reserve and the
government six trillion dollars that's a
lot in three years here's what happened
to us the last time our national debt
GDP to national debt ratio when you look
at this year was a hundred percent was
1945 right after World War II that's
that's catastrophic when you go back and
have to go to that number to see when's
the last time we were there so the
government is sitting there it's like a
car driving at an 8 000 RPM
boom engine blows up you can't do this
for too long so we're looking at this
saying wait a minute 98.2 percent during
covet 2020 yeah it went close to 130 at
some point and if this thing continues
with the debt to GDP ratio look what it
can go to next in 2030 2040. so the FED
is sitting they're concerned what are we
going to do about this the government's
sitting there concerned presidents
sitting there concerned wall Street's
sitting there concerned everybody's
sitting there concerned saying how are
we going to handle this what are we
going to do about this well government
regulation intensified fracking permits
cut and oil pipelines canceled
cancellation of Keystone pipelines
resulted in thousands of construction
jobs lost billions in financial impact
all of this is going on then he got the
Russia Ukraine war created additional
supply issues some said what oil you
know the north stream pipeline who did
it was it us was it Russia was it NATO
who was involvement distincture we don't
know but that created a bunch of ruckus
bottom line money supply went up and
available Goods went down okay what
happens when this takes place people
have money but we don't have available
Goods inflation Goes Wild prices start
going up too slow too fast for us to
respond the FED held zero percent
interest rates and purchase 120 billion
dollars per month of treasuries and more
get back mortgage-backed Securities
which is called quantitative easing they
buy from Banks right they're buying
instead of taking money out they're
putting money in right quantitative
tightening let's take money out of the
market quantitative easing let's put
money on the market this is what we're
doing during covet there'll print some
more money put the money in there put
the money on the economy okay okay look
how much man the rich are getting richer
and the poor are getting poor but damn
this is awesome look at all these
policies how great are they man and then
why are the Richer getting richer
because bad policies have consequences
and no matter how much money you print
and put into the economy guess what the
rich know how to do save invest and grow
their money guess what the poor know how
to do spend and waste their money and
when they spend and waste their money
who does it go to companies owned by the
rich so as much as it was a noble thing
to do the disparity between the rich and
the poor got wider and wider and wider
even though the intentions were Noble it
became catastrophic let me continue you
Jerome Powell says well you know we
believe inflation is going to be
transitory and nobody's worried about it
a couple years ago we're like ah it's
fine it's gonna be no not a big deal
it's good suddenly pivots and starts
aggressively raising rates like never
before and here's what it looks like
zero percent interest rate hikes for two
years if you look at the bottom left it
says July 2020
up until January 2022 we're not doing
anything then all of a sudden we raise
five percent in one year what happens
when you raise rates five percent in one
year well let's see how many times we've
done this before but before we do so
what happens here so fed hiking rates
achieved price stability caused a shock
to the banking sector like ways we've
never seen before okay you don't see it
but behind closed doors like oh my God
these banks are about to have a heart
attack on the outside they're walking
they're fine on the inside this heart is
having to pump so hard and it can't keep
up bone then you got a heart attack so
unprecedented action they have to take
normally FDIC only ensures deposits up
to 250 that's what the number is
government guaranteed all Silicon Valley
Bank depositors we've not done this
before ninety percent of Silicon Valley
Bank deposits were over a quarter of a
million dollars this is Silicon Valley
so the clientele is slightly different
so it's not like it's everybody's gonna
be fine nah 90 is not going to be fine
because they have more than a quarter
million dollars and it's always paying
for this you know is it going to be be
taxpayers no it's not going to be
taxpayers it's the FDIC you don't have
to worry about it Biden said the
taxpayers are not going to pay for but
did not explain how the taxpayers are
not going to pay for it what are you
going to do are you going to print some
more money and not tell us about it and
just put on the balance sheet I mean you
would never do that right I would never
happen with the fed well maybe we'll see
what actually happens so are more banks
at risk
this is the question everybody's been
asking the last two weeks okay is
Charles Schwab about to go down is the
next band you know Credit Suisse what
happened there 10 billion dollars 12
days you know if companies like this
well they've been bad for four years
it's not a news and well Schwab's been
irresponsible for no it would never
happen to Schwab all these names and I'm
not just telling you Schwab is one of
them there's a lot of lists that people
are talking about behind closed doors
so what is this chart here here's what
this chart shows us here
when when the moment everybody looked at
Silicon Valley Bank to see what
percentage of their asset under Mass
management
was under bonds was allocated to bonds
everybody started looking at this chart
so Silicon Valley Bank 63 percent of
their assets was in bonds you know how
they bought 100 billion dollar Bond over
a three year period at 1.7 percent so
that 100 billion and there were 200
billion including on another 30 billion
they have about 63 percent of all their
assets is tied to bonds so who looks
safe here who looks risky here JPMorgan
Chase is the safest Bank out there what
everybody started talking about only 15
percent is tied to bonds then it's B of
A 26 then a city 34 Dennis Wells then he
got U.S bank then he got PNC then he got
some of these other names Goldman Sach
sack sitting at 52 percent TD Waterhouse
Capital One and then you got uh Morgan
Stanley private at 63 percent but then
some of the other names they're like
wait a minute I know these Banks what's
going to happen with HSBC if you look at
HSBC 70
what's going to happen with Comerica
Bank I know Comerica Bank how about
first horizon how about Frost how about
CIBC 79 percent
is long-term bonds or bonds what are we
talking about here should we be worried
is this going to happen to my bank odds
are if you're watching this one of those
is your bank that you're banking with
odds are if you're watching this one of
those is a bank you're banking with if
some of you are saying nope I don't bank
with any of those you may be banking
with a Community Bank and a Community
Bank is for cities with less than 50 000
people a population it's a smaller
Community Banks it's a smaller cities
that have you know banks that size you
may be with one of those but everybody
started looking at Banks to the right of
Silicon Valley and that's a lot of names
could they be next and talk starts well
if it can happen to them it can happen
to others as well
so then all of the stuff they're talking
about the FDIC says no you don't need to
worry about it we got it covered we're
gonna be fine this is the FDIC we got
plenty of money we're sitting there
and then some people became curious and
they said well how much is the FDIC
insuring how much deposits all the stuff
that says
up to 250 000 of you know deposits
insured at the banks how much are you
trying to ensure oh it's only 9.9
trillion dollars of deposits
how much do you currently have
available to you that in case something
were to happen can you cover
the 9.9 trillion it's going to be fine
can you show us the balance sheet so
some people post this on Twitter and it
went viral
to protect the 9.9 trillion dollars you
see such as it says in short deposits
this is their balance sheet the fdic's
balance sheet you see how much the fund
balance has only 125 billion dollars
[Laughter]
only 125 billion dollars they have How
You Gonna protect everybody well only
125 billion dollars at 9.9 trillion
dollars how are you going to do it FDIC
and they're like oh my God people are
panicking phone call phone call phone
call I'm assuming they're having
conference calls you cannot let this
happen we have to get people to relax
unemployment is low we got to keep it
low we can't get people to panic what if
they start all of a sudden taking their
monies out of Banks and we cannot
everybody has to cover these stories
this is not good this is tragic this is
scary okay
what people are learning now a little
bit of the FDIC situation so then you
know the money the stimulus that we did
in covet look at the right and look at
the left in 2008 the tarp program that
they did which was roughly 800 billion
dollars do you see when you zoom in
where it says January 2009 between
January 2009 and January 2008 in that uh
the the glass that is had that's looking
at uh where we're at
that's 800 billion dollars
can you even see the subtle increase
look how subtle it is right now go to
the right look what covet stimulus look
like Skyrocket and look at the angle
what it looks like okay when we did this
so now
this man here has got a tough job okay
uh there are a lot of jobs you can have
you can be a president you can be a lot
of different jobs today it's very hard
to have this guy's job he does not have
an easy job because what he's going
through today no fed share has ever gone
through because the current climate is
very unique and I'll explain to you why
so there's two ways he can take this he
can take the Ben Bernanke route and be
dovish or he can take the Paul volcker
out and be hawkish
so Ben Bernanke was a Fed chair from
2006 to 2014 it was under President Bush
and Obama and the biggest problem he was
facing was the 2008 crisis during his
eight years of being in office so
interest rates height was five percent
low zero percent it's a pretty decent
time to do what he did and his problem
was 2008 okay so now volcker on the
right look at him fetcher from 79 to 87
it was Jimmy Carter and Ronald Reagan
biggest problem with inflation and it
was the worst in a long time height 19
and the low was six percent height
19 is where it was at so Powell if you
had the job you would say I want to see
the data of what the guys before me did
and how they handle this some of them
you can call to ask for advice some of
them you can't call right so let me see
the case study what do they do here why
do they do that what should we do here
and here's what we saw Ben Bernanke
similar to 2020 2021 Powell Powell used
bernanke's strategy in 2020 2021 but
Powell used volcker strategy in 2022 to
now
so on the left the Bernanke strategy was
trading Comfort today for pain tomorrow
hey let's lower interest rates let's
make sure we're good now but man the
Next Generation our kids and grandkids
will pay price for but come on let's at
least us be good right now we can't lose
all our money right now versus the Paul
volcker style is like no no we can't
give this inheritance to our kids we got
to take a hit in the economy now so we
can have a better economy for them it's
unfair for us to give them our screw-up
of what we did which is kind of noble
so then Bernanke middle and lower class
priced out of real estate can't afford
it 2006 houses millionaire I can't
afford to buy a million dollars this
thing was 400 000 or just six years ago
well it's a million dollars now but I
can't afford to buy it I can't make a
payment like that I get it but other
people are and legit no income no assets
just tell us what income you got Finance
it anyways you know and you know get a
low interest rate get to your interest
only it's going to be great I was just
talking to my guy about buying
commercial real estate I'm looking at
this building that we're uh wanting to
made an offer on from 89 million to 69
million to 59 million to 46 million okay
and to 46 million the people that are in
it right now that we were talking to we
had a meeting with them two three months
ago they can't get the financing
completed why because of what's going on
right now okay people cannot so the
funding the interest rates all of a
sudden all the loans that they got on
short-term interest rates we can get it
get it interest rates are going to stay
low for all of us forever boom hello
rates are no longer 2.9 percent at six
and a half your payment is officially
this can you make it
can you give us 30 more days I'll give
you 30 more days what do we do now you
got to sell some of your assets we got
to figure something out and then boom
next one the Paul Walker route is asset
prices goes down and unemployment goes
up either way this one pain is a
different kind of a pain than this
Powell has used both strategies which is
kind of off and a little bit weird so
what do we do next so when you look at
this here this tells you story here the
Volker years
you see from 79 to 87 this is what he
was dealing with you see inflation all
the way at the top 19 and if you go to
the bottom you don't see anything below
six percent pretty much not Unemployment
uh interest rates is what you see 19 at
the high six percent at the bottom okay
these numbers today people would Panic
if we got to 19 so this is more Bernanke
it was the high of five and a quarter
and then he brought it down and kept at
less than half a point for 128 months
that's why they call it 128 month
economic expansion people making money
left and right fake success left and
right oh let me get another 50 million
dollar line let me get another 10
million dollar line at such and such
interest rate money is free get it as
much as you want we're going to be like
this forever what they don't realize is
they screwed it up for their kids and
grandkids because it can't be this easy
money can't be this cheap it's fake if
it's this cheap but they said keep doing
it it's working don't tell anybody we're
gonna have to pay price 10 years from
now keep rolling the dice it's cool a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more and then boom here's
what happens Powell used the old
strategy the last two years and now he's
using the new strategy the last 12
months okay so what's the difference
here's what you got to look at the
challenge he's got is the following
Bernanke had a crisis with low inflation
two to four percent volcker had
inflation uh with a low debt to GDP
ratio 30 to 40 percent debt to GDP ratio
that was his you know what Pals is
Powell is dealing with high inflation
and high debt to GDP he's got both of
their problems at the same time
happening
what do you do six to nine percent
inflation and a hundred two hundred
thirty percent debt to GDP ratio what do
you do with that so this is what I'm
telling you this is this guy's got a
tough job one minute everyone's telling
them hey let's go to Bernanke route
another man is like no no no let's go to
volkrat no no let's go this one what are
we gonna do here I can't make up my mind
so he's like flip-flopping I go this
right I go down I go this right go this
side
rather than sticking to his guns to one
philosophy people behind closed doors
are constantly influenced and
influencing him to change his approach
and watch what just recently happened
which a lot of people are now talking
about you see this right here the FED
made a huge move last week that no one
is talking about look at the top right
do you see the top right okay that
magnifying glass shows you a small
little tick up above that 8 million do
you see that it doesn't look like a big
number how big of a deal is that it's
not really that big of a deal here's
what they just did last week okay they
added 300 billion dollars okay to their
balance sheet just one day the fedges
decided to add 300 billion dollars to
their balance sheet in one day so what
does this mean let me kind of undo this
to show you what he did for the last six
months okay if you look at this look at
the chart of where it went where it says
8.639 obviously that's in billions okay
in millions so if you look at that 300
billion dollars they just added to now
8.69 trillion okay that's what the 300
billion is
you go back five months ago or six
months ago to November we were the same
so whatever he's done the last five or
six months they just undid all of these
increasing the rates increasing the
rates increasing rates they just undid
by adding 300 billion dollars to the
balance sheet
Pat what are you saying they undid
the vocal strategy he was taking now he
went back to the Bernanke strategy so
that's what it looks like okay 300
billion dollars at it no one's talking
about it no one's talking about it and
it was you know the bigger Bank CEOs are
coming out and saying yeah you know we
got two trillion dollars if if we're not
going to let these Regional Banks go out
of business in the communities they're
going to be safe and they got another
two trillion dollars added into it that
in case something happens I know my
friends at the big five banks they're
not going to tap into that it's going to
be the regional and the community ones
we're not going to let these Banks go
out of business what does that sound
like putting more money into the economy
that's what you call quantitative
easing what do you think that money goes
to to the big Banks okay that money is
going to roll back to them is what's
going to happen the bigger Banks don't
care the bigger Banks benefit from some
like this okay when this happens but you
and I
we kind of have to pay for this okay the
price goes back to you and matter of
fact low and middle income they pay the
biggest price because that whole concept
these guys get up on stage sounds so
Noble like Robin Hood you know it's like
let me tell you it's not fair that the
rich getting richer and the poor getting
poorer you just added 300 billion
dollars to the balance sheet that if you
have to build these guys that that money
is going to who
is that money going to
if you decide to bail out these other
Regional and communities where is that
money going to tell me is that money
going to go in the hands of uh the the
small guy is it going to go to the
middle income guys who's that money
going to go to how about the guy that's
making small money and all of a sudden
we got a new guy that's rich and look at
all this money that they're making look
how awesome this is
they sound Noble but they're
catastrophic Powell was this close of
going through what he was going through
maybe he increased five percent in 12
months maybe that was a little bit too
dramatic because when you see what
happens here next it'll tell you a story
but we were so close in taking the
volcker route which was the Reagan side
to come out of what Carter did but we
went back to the Bernanke route so now
Bank term funding program
after Silicon Valley the the FED set up
a program to prevent another event like
it from happening Silicon Valley Bank
lost money selling bonds before maturity
the FED has guaranteed credit for Bank
bonds at a hundred percent of the bond
value
you know what that means don't worry
about it take all the risks we'll bail
you out at a hundred percent at a
hundred percent of your bond value what
if it's not worth that don't worry we
got you it's gonna be cool okay let me
go back to being Reckless again that's
what kind of happens because it's like
the kid that no matter every time he
gets in trouble mommy and daddy bail him
out so that kid becomes a spoiled rotten
kid and it's because of Mommy and Daddy
and in this situation mommy and daddy is
the government and the Fed
that's what happens and these bankers at
the top become spoiled because every
time they go out of their way to build
these guys out and they've become
spoiled little brats without letting any
one of these guys go out of business
I've made a lot of mistakes in my life
and I paid a price for it and it sucked
some of it took me a year to recover
from my mistake some of it took me five
years to recover from a mistake okay
five years one of it took me seven years
to recover from my mistake it's supposed
to suck when you take a risk and you're
reckless and you're not responsible
there's a price to be paid for it right
this is going on in front of our eyes
and a lot of people are sitting around
saying are we going to be okay with this
we're about to find out what happens
next watch this BT uh FP is a game
changer Bank term funding program they
just launched the margin will be a
hundred percent of par value you know
what this means they're going to protect
the banks no matter what it is with the
bonds use it's lost money it's no longer
worth what it was before don't worry
about it we're going to protect that at
100 of par value okay it's so funny I
mean the if the average investor it's
like going to the casino playing
roulette playing any game you want to
play and the boss of the casino comes to
you and says listen don't worry about it
you won't play a hundred thousand
dollars don't worry play Reckless put
100 000 on 36. boom I didn't get it
another hundred thousand don't worry 22.
I lost it all oh my another hundred
thousand what a noble guide this is
where's that money coming from
where's that money coming from it's
coming from somewhere
it is coming from somewhere so where is
the risk there is no risk for these guys
there's no risk the risk is for you but
there's no risk for these guys so
at least inflation is going down right A
lot of people are saying well
inflation's going down it's great okay
look at the numbers we are below what we
were before and uh from a year ago it's
fantastic everybody should be happy
really is that really the case have we
always measured successive inflation
going down on a 12-month marker or a 24
month marker meaning isn't it supposed
to be where inflation is at today
versus two years ago to say if we're
higher or for lower huh because if
that's the case inflation is still very
high but they're not selling it that way
because I think they just change
something so let's take a look at this
this is kind of interesting every year
on February 14th there's a celebration
of love this February BLS which is the
U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics
government the Consumer Price Index
which we hope you uh will love beginning
with January 2023 index scheduled for
publication of February 14 2023 BLS
plans to update the spending weights in
the calculation of CPI every year
instead of every two years
what
yeah every year instead of every two
years why are you doing that well we're
just changing it isn't that great
because it's the power of positive
thinking you don't have to know the
negative stuff let's just stay positive
and that's how we're going to fix the
economy by us staying positive isn't
that kind of cool I don't I don't
understand what you're saying here yes
so they change the way they measure it
here's what it means the typical way
we've always measured uh inflation is
two years meaning where is inflation at
today versus where we were two years ago
if we measure where inflation is at
today versus two years ago which is 1.7
percent the numbers are real scary
versus if you measure where inflation is
at today
versus where inflation was at a year ago
7.9 percent they get to say inflation is
down so here's how it looks old way
measurement of two years New Way
measurement of one year old way CPI
February was 2021 and 2021 was 1.7 new
way let's go back to February of 2022.
it was 7.9 percent we're getting better
always current inflation is six percent
New Way current inflation is six percent
old way inflation is up still 4.3
percent in a new measurement inflation
is down 1.9 percent
do you see what they're doing do you see
how this whole by the way everything I'm
sharing with you go to your own due
diligence and research and all that
stuff
for yourself we're just giving you stuff
off the government website we're not
giving you stuff that is off blogs this
is off the Bureau of Labor Statistics
website stuff that you can go look up
yourself as well so now let's continue
the FED also just raised interest rates
Court of a base respond which by the way
I kind of like the fact that they did
that they stuck to their guns some
people were afraid he was going to do
half a point but he went up only a
quarter of a basis point everyone's
wondering what he's going to do next is
he going to do quarter quarter he's
going to do half quarter is he gonna do
nothing then he's going to go half
quarter we don't know obviously we will
see what happens because if there is
another bank or two or three that this
happens to like Silicon Valley Bank they
may not do anything for a couple months
and go back to the Bernanke way of
managing the crisis that we have today
so this is all new and the outcome is
very uncertain nobody really knows what
they're talking about including myself
I'm just saying to what's going on today
in the marketplace
everybody I talked to at Goldman at
Morgan you watch the guys on television
everybody's telling you nobody's been
here before
we're all playing it by ears to see
what's going to happen
part of it is control which you can
control part of it is there's certain
things we have zero control over if your
name's not yelling if your name's not
Powell if your name's not Biden if your
name's not one of the five CEOs of major
banks in America Jamie Diamond and some
of these other guys
you're probably not going to be be
involved in much of these
decision-making process this is what is
going on today and they're all trying to
learn how to get out of this mess while
they're learning and they're doing and
they have to sound confident and
optimistic with you and I this has all
happened at the same time so now
remember how I told you we increased
five percent in one year
in 2008 2004 to 2008 they raised
interest rates four percent but they did
it in two years
that's going to affect the economy this
time we did five years five percent in
one year
that's a lot in a year that's what a lot
of people are talking about this is kind
of why we're facing what we're facing
right now with banks sitting there
saying I can't afford to make my
payments right now what are we going to
do so unemployment okay if you look at
this unemployment will Skyrocket is what
a lot of people are talking about in
2005 to 2010 if you look at this 2005 to
2019 unemployment was below six percent
it was below four and a half percent in
around 2007 and then all of a sudden
went up to six seven and a half nine ten
percent they're afraid of this
this is what they're afraid of because
when this happened in 2008 and we
haven't experience by the way covid has
got nothing to do with this while covet
kind of covet had nothing to do with the
economy kova was coveted had nothing to
do with the economy this is the real
economy we're talking about here the
last time when this happened in 2008
when unemployment went the race that it
went here's what happened to suicide
rate in America from 2007 8 9 10. do you
see the numbers exceeding that's what it
was like
4750 excess death that took place it's
scary I remember I was in that economy
that's what they're doing to the economy
right now
so for me I make a lot of calls and I
talk to a lot of business owners small
business owners entrepreneurs
two years ago and I'm talking to them
they were afraid of what Cove is going
to do to their business in 2021 a lot of
them are making more money than ever
before 2022 they were uncertain people
I'm talking to right now who were
sitting on a few million dollars they're
not as confident as they were a year ago
I'm having different kind of
conversations with people today this is
reality of what's coming right now new
startups vanished in 2008 when they took
this approach look at the 2007 to 2009
chart look what happened with the number
of startups it went all the way down to
numbers we had in 1994 even lower than
the numbers we had in 1994. we all know
small business owners employ nearly 49
of people in America have a job because
of a small business owner what happens
when we lose small startups okay they're
not getting funding anymore what happens
with those guys because you know the
banks tighten and they don't lend the
way that they typically do startups pay
price for it so now here is a number of
births and deaths after 2008. look at
this birth went up 2002 3-4 we're having
a lot of babies we're on fire from 90
three
having babies 94 95 96 97 we're having
babies babies babies babies 2008.
all of a sudden boom
Philips on us Bert's goes down death
goes up people are scared well what
they're doing now I'm not trying to
scare the crap out of you right now
trust me I was in that economy and it
was scary I got involved in this
business in the 2001 economy 911. my
first day was 9 10. okay day before 9
11. I started off being scared about
this industry and having to be paranoid
because I wasn't a bad market for a few
years I never thought this thing was
going to work out for me I thought I was
going to go back to the military because
I didn't think this was going to happen
for me being the financial industry got
involved by possibly the worst time you
could have gotten involved in the
financial industry the last four years 9
10 2001 okay a day before 9 11. let's
take a quick timeout if you're going
through it right now a couple things I
want you to be thinking about don't make
any irresponsible decisions right now
delay them till next year I'm talking a
lot of weird decisions right now people
want to make delay till next year just
because you're in this place right now
doesn't mean it'll remain like this
forever okay keep yourself busy with as
many positive actions as possible and
avoid having too much time on your hands
let me give you a couple things here
about this message I'm giving to you
alcohol
don't touch it right now try to avoid it
any kind of sleep medication any of that
stuff my recommend I'm not a doctor I'm
not giving you I'm just telling you like
you see a lot of this stuff happening to
people right now and they kind of want
to numb themselves to not go through
this pain you're a real estate guy
making 100 Grand a month you're not now
you're making Seven Grand a month and
you and your wife and family are going
through a lot of issues you have to give
away that car of yours the lambo the
rolls you were going to sushi spots now
you're eating at Chipotle and you're
eating the Chipotle bowls is what you're
doing with that red dressing that they
have but it ain't sushi it ain't
maestros it ain't Flemings it ain't that
sushi spot you were going to and having
sea urchin anymore okay now you're going
back to ghetto California roll out of
Kroger's or Publix or Albertsons or
Ralph's I don't know where you live in
that's what you're kind of going back to
and it's embarrassing because you went
from the rock star going to parties with
a nice three-piece suit on and a nice
watch and now you're going out there and
it's the same clothes and you're kind of
embarrassed and afraid because people
are looking at you and people can sense
fear right
if you're thinking about getting a
divorce wait two years if you still feel
like getting a divorce in two years do
it
if you're thinking about throwing the
towel in right now wait two years if you
feel like that then consider it then but
not right now no major Crazy Life making
decisions today none just go through the
season and a couple things that I'll
share with you here to help you out idle
time scary right now if you got too much
idle time nobody can think straight who
does not work idleness warps the Mind
Henry Ford any time I've ever done
anything stupid in my life I had too
much time on my hand I was a young guy I
got out of the military I didn't have a
job for about a month my hair color was
orange because I had peroxide in it and
I was going to Zuma Beach in La you know
with a Malibu and I was putting peroxide
if you know what I'm talking about you
know what I'm you don't know what I'm
talking about like why would you put
peroxide in this sir trust me don't go
try this at home and go put peroxide in
here saying hey how come this happened
to my hair I had nothing to do I had way
too much time on my hands I was doing
the dumbest things at that time because
I had too much time on my hands okay
number two Purge your mind of all
aimless and idle thoughts especially
those that pry into the Affairs of
others or wish them ill this is a wrong
attempt to be thinking about I hope that
guy goes out of business I hope that guy
goes bankrupt I hope that guy does this
I hope that don't even let your mind
consume any of those thoughts as
somebody come to our house the other day
and this person was talking about let me
tell you those people are evil and that
person is this and that person is this
and these people I'm like I don't even
want to put those thoughts in my head
right now everybody's dealing with
something right now okay everybody is I
am you are we all are the wealthy people
are the politicians are Jerome Powell is
trust me everybody's dealing with
something right now I want everybody to
have a good life and I want everybody to
do their parts and have their dreams
become a reality so my focus is really
my life and doing what I can do with my
life don't be thinking about hoping
other things you know bad things happen
to other people they gotta also go
through it just like you're going
through right now trouble Springs from
idleness and Grievious toil from
needless ease Benjamin Franklin next
Thomas Jefferson determined never to be
idle no person will have occasion to
complain of the want of time who never
loses any it is wonderful how much can
be done if we are always doing this is a
season to be doing this is not a season
to be sitting around this is by far the
worst time to be sitting around not
doing an idle time worried about how
this economy is going to affect you so
things to keep in mind during turbulent
times you need to uh you need to write
emotional
response especially if you're in a
leadership position your father your
parent your CEO your boss your sales
leader your manager your supervisor the
people are looking at you to show Poise
it doesn't mean you're a robot it
doesn't mean you're a machine it doesn't
mean you have to be perfect but they're
leaning on you to be able to hold
yourself together and stay strong okay
you need to write strategies at a time
like this when I went through this I was
not the best salesperson I had no clue
what I was doing every time I was
working at Morgan Stanley Dean with her
and I was doing what I was doing not
knowing if I'm going to make it or not
every day all I kept telling myself Pat
why are you putting yourself through
this just go back in the army man you
were great in the Army go do 20 years
you were 63 Bravo Humber mechanic Fort
Campbell Kentucky still got a bunch of
friends you know the streets you know
what to do you know the formation you
know the acronyms you know all the stuff
you were good at it man just go back
just go back you're going to get a bonus
if you join you'll pay off your debt you
know do 20 years you'll get out at 38
years old you'll have a pension to pay
you for the rest of your life maybe 50
if you do 30 years maybe maybe you'll
get 75 percent or 100 percent if you get
disability get 100 just go do that why
don't you not doing that that's all I
was thinking about okay while I'm going
through 9 11 I'm like dude this is the
worst position I could have been in
getting my Series 7 license right after
9 11 takes place you could have joined
this four years ago you made some kind
of money at least without summon savings
no you got involved in the worst time
just go on the army so I needed the
right strategies because I was not
making it and selling I was not a good
salesperson in the high ticket items I
could sell five ten dollar products
maybe 100 products maybe even thousand
dollar products I did not know how to
sit down with millionaires at Morgan
Stanley selling a million dollar fund or
roll over four hundred thousand dollars
in their 401K in 2001 I didn't know how
to do that you need to maintain a level
of poise this is very valuable right now
to be able to stay poised in a time like
this okay everybody is watching you if
you're a leader and if you're not
if you are a regular guy you're not a
leader you're you're a person that may
be a potential future Superstar this is
when people will identify let me tell
you I'm really impressed by that guy
look how poised he is look how poisonous
she is in a family look how poisonous
that person is look how poisonous person
is you show signs of future leadership
and Seasons like this unfortunately
times of Crisis is a great filtering
system to identify who's a real leader
and who's not you can never tell who's a
real leader in Good Times you can only
tell who's a real leader with poise
during bad times only good times fake
bad times real leadership is exposed you
need to have the right level of urgency
to find a solution it's not a time to
sit around and be thinking about what
about this and what about that and what
about this Buffett says something very
powerful
years ago it says it takes 20 years to
build a reputation and five minutes to
ruin it if you think about what you'll
do things differently if you think about
that you'll do things differently right
you got 20 years you've done the right
things five minutes to ruin it that's
why I said if you're about to make a bad
decision you know marriage kids finances
all this stuff take two years before you
make a big decision because even though
times may be hard if you were good at
what you were doing a year ago two years
ago three years ago you've learned a lot
this is just a bad time you're in right
now and it's a time that none of us have
ever experienced in the history of
America before that all things are
hitting at the same time to the economy
you ain't been through this before okay
and partially you're not at fault but it
is your responsibility and my
responsibility to do the best with
whatever hands that we've been dealt
right now that's the moves we gotta make
okay you and I especially if you
consider yourself a leader and by the
way if you're on a podcast like this
you're on a show like this you're
watching this webinar right now A lot of
people are not on this think about how
many people could have been on this
they're not on this one why not you're
watching a show they're probably
watching a Netflix show they're probably
listening to music right now they're
watching YouTube videos they don't have
time for this they're sitting around
worried stressed out idle time checking
Instagram stories checking Tick Tock
stories you chose to take the time to
get on something like this this means
you're showing leadership qualities
yourself kudos to you not a lot of
people are doing it right now they're
trying to go through this in a way to
eliminate the pressure and what's really
going on but you're saying I want to
face the reality and I want to get some
strategies that can work for me I
applaud you for so how to approach a
crisis like this what caused it is it in
your control or out of your control
quantifying the risk of Crisis worst
case scenario what's the worst thing
that's going to happen here really let's
think about what's the worst thing
that's going to happen here a market
crash you know a bad one 20 30 could
depression really take place could a War
take place how bad can this thing get
can it get very bad to the point that it
could cause caused me to lose my job
lose my clients okay am I the first
person that's going through this now how
long do you think this will last you
think this will last for 10 years now
you think it's a five-year deal no you
think it's a one year two year deal most
likely okay I can kind of go through
that but I want to come out of it a
winner this is what I want to come I
don't want to just come out worse than
what I am today I want to be able to
come out with a higher market value than
before great that's the right way of
thinking three confront the crisis with
the right level of urgency sometimes
when issues happen in our lives we're
kind of like I got time it's okay next
month next week next this thing yeah you
can't you can't afford to do that right
now
you can afford to do that in Good Times
you you cannot afford to not have
urgency in bad times like this zero you
cannot afford to have it find the roots
of the crisis to eliminate future
repetition of the event maybe the
industry you're a part of maybe a
product you're selling maybe you didn't
save enough money maybe about one too
many Exotics maybe you buy one too many
watches maybe you didn't take advantage
of the market when I was doing very good
and he sat on the sidelines you're like
man I didn't even make any money Pat
I've never even experienced making money
maybe you need to get into the market
maybe you need to play ball maybe you
need to stop sitting on the sidelines
that's not working for you what we do
know is with all of the stuff that's
going on the marketplace right now
making six figures today you got to get
your income to a whole different level
you gotta position yourself in a place
with a company that upside is big long
term for you you have to be starting to
think about those thoughts depending on
your age you may be 35 right now with
two kids saying hey man I got to kind of
start thinking about long term for
myself exactly but find the roots of the
crisis to eliminate future repetition of
the event create a battle plan both
defensive and offensive so now timeline
of Crisis okay one hour don't turn a
issue that you need to resolve in an
hour and let it last a day don't let an
issue that's supposed to last only a day
and linger for a week you're wasting
your time don't let a crisis that a one
week long crisis take a month of your
life don't let a month crisis take a
quarter don't like a quarter take a year
don't don't let a year take a decade
away from you learn to condense time
frames in times like this while you're
going through this crisis don't be
overthinking your decision we gotta go
we gotta go we got to be decisive in a
time like this you know what's the book
I recommended this last podcast that we
talked about how to make decisive
decisions the books the books title the
books entire premise was around how to
make decisive decisions now in this
climate because it's important to make
that's a very valuable skill set today
to make so now let me show you this I uh
uh Kai we came out with a short what two
year years ago three years ago I think
it's two years ago two or three years
ago when we were in Boca and this this
is what the whole concept was the last
20 some years ever since I got out of
the military and I've been working in
free market free enterprise financial
industry I've watched a lot of my peers
on my competitors and here's what I
noticed if you look at the bottom right
the red represents the one percent the
orange represents the 10 percent of your
industry yellow represents 20 percent
and the green represents eighty percent
of people in your field okay here's what
I learned
I learned that almost everybody can work
just as hard as anybody on any given day
almost everybody can work as hard as
anybody on any given week
but they can't do it over a month span
over a quarter over a year over a decade
that's when they get exposed so if you
look at the difference between the red
it's all the way at the top okay when
they're running and gunning they're
running at nine and a half but they're
low only gets as low as eight
if you look at the top 10 percent when
they're running and gunning they can
compete with the one percent at nine and
a half but when they're cruising they
drop all the way down to six
when you look at the top 20 percent at
the top they can compete with the one
percent at nine and a half but when
they're chilling their low drops to four
and if you look at the green the green
will get to an eight and a half they'll
never work as hard as everybody else but
with their bottom when they're cruising
when times are hard man they truly
disappear and it takes them years to
recover from it I don't know which one
you are okay just by being on this here
I'm assuming you're automatically
probably in the 20 or higher But
whichever one you are remember when
people lap you or they get past you or
they beat you it's typically typically
during scary times while a lot of people
are in idle not doing anything it's just
kind of like well you know my God you
know the times are very hard I can't
find a job I can't do this I can't do
that
they make urgent decisions and move do
not be the person that you use a Bad
season like this to say this is why I'm
not working as hard because there's just
not any business out there there's just
not any clients out there there's plenty
of business out there to do for the
people that are going above and beyond
and doing what others are not willing to
do next skills dictates your value in
the marketplace today we're hiring a
bunch of people right now
in this building right now we have what
is the number 65 full-time employees we
have 65 full-time employees now a year
ago we were at 25. a year prior to that
we were at eight okay so we went from
eight to 25 to now 65 and we can't fit
in this building if I open that door and
you come into this building people are
sitting on top of each other literally
we bought another building that we
turned into a comedy club and a cigar
lounge now people are going to be
working out of there we've made multiple
offers to buy different buildings in
community because we need more space
people are hiring today we currently
have 18 job openings today positions
right now whether it's sales
editor-in-chief VP of Studios president
of Studios we have so many different
managing director of our consulting firm
we got so many job openings today that
we're looking okay ourselves
so what are people looking for I did a
training this week just to talk to my
guests to see how good they are at sales
and negotiation because my job is to
train the trainers to make sure all my
guys know how to negotiate all my guys
know how to sell how good are you at
selling yourself how good are your
people at selling how good are the
people you're working without
negotiating what skill sets are you
adding in an economy like this to
separate yourself from everybody else in
the marketplace well this is this is me
in the in the picture to the right
that's that's uh if you look it says
2001 that's exactly right after 9 11.
the girl in the back right behind that
uh White flash that's a girl named Seoul
we were sharing the same desk at Morgan
Stanley Deanwood or building in Glendale
I am in that picture 22 years old in
that picture I'm 22 years old okay
the picture to the left I'm in my office
in Northridge I'm sitting on my computer
looking at what's going on with those
old earpieces look at that old earpiece
before Apple came out with their
earpiece the earpie what did he call it
earpods is that what it's called the
earpods that's the ghetto ones I don't
even know what they called it back in
the days but it was it is that's what
the Nextel combination I got my CDs in
the corner you see that CD box at the
top I'm listening to CDs I'm constantly
trying to figure out ways to improve
with that camel hair jacket of mine who
was so hot I'm wearing it in LA while
it's 100 degrees right trying to look
like I know what I'm doing but I am in
the hunt
I'm in the office early I'm in the
office late I'm extremely paranoid I'm
extremely concerned about what's going
on but at the same time I am so
optimistic because I'm smelling
opportunity
that kid right there I call him kid it
was 28 years old that guy right there is
so flipping hungry he sees an
opportunity and he knows this is his
chance to become the hero to his family
I at 44 I'm grateful to both of these
guys
I look at this right now and I say thank
you to both of them because the guy on
the right and 22 years old he was a
little too good at partying so the fact
that he kind of put it on pause I'm
proud of him and the guy right there
while he was having some success he did
not slow down to celebrate oh my god
look how special you are he kept saying
I can do a little bit more at the next
phase because I'm going to be able to
have my family's dreams become a reality
and I was in Recreation mode it's not
easy to do because what Recreation mode
is mode is to tell yourself I'm not good
enough for the next phase so I learned
the skill set of sales then I learned
how to become a sales Leader by the way
learning how to be a sales leader this
helps you in everything you do in life
just so you know Trump is a salesperson
and he's a sales leader okay Obama
salesperson and a sales leader just so
you know this by the way Bill Clinton
for sure he's a salesperson and a sales
leader even Bush even Reagan Kennedy
Nixon these guys learn how to sell and
how to drive people
sales leaders know how to move people I
knew how to sell but I hadn't learned
how to drive sales people myself so then
I became a CEO
each time I learned new skill set that
increased my market value I didn't know
what it was to be a CEO I was a business
owner but I was not a good CEO I spent
fifty thousand dollars in went and lived
in Boston for three weeks at Harvard
Business School at their OPM program to
learn how to become a CEO so I was a
terrible CEO I was like a business owner
I was not a good CEO I don't know what
to track I don't know what to do on a
daily basis I knew at each phase I had
to recreate myself just like this iPhone
which system are we on right now is it
iOS 14 or 15 whatever it is just like
this thing has upgrades you need to have
your own upgrades maybe you were good
for the last level but you ain't good
for the next level so what are you doing
to recreate yourself in a season like
this sales is a skill that changed my
life if you got value out of this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel I got two other things I want
you to think about as well one if you
want to know what drives you your
personality during a time like this are
you scared what gets you to move in a
time like this we created this quiz for
you to learn about yourself if you've
never taken as Clues before to see which
one before you fall under click here
take the quiz go other one is how to
make tough decisions a video we did four
years ago if you've never seen it click
here to watch it take everybody bye
foreign